character cannot be developed in ease
and quiet only through experience of
trial and suffering can the Soul be
strengthened ambition inspired and
success achieved
tolerance is a fundamental character
trait of great people
and a part of the attitudes and
practices of those we admire and respect
people without tolerance are diminished
and poor
how we behave toward and around our
children has much more influence on
their character than if we only tell
them about how they should or should not
behave
patience is not simply one thing it is a
concept that transcends many areas of
our personal makeup and affects nearly
every characteristic and behavior we
possess or act on
we are not just products of our past
people in our present also influence us
and help mold our character
your character defines Who You Are by
the actions you take
what man's mind can create man's
character should control
[Music]
when people grow in character they grow
in the ability to set and receive
boundaries in their marriages and they
mature
[Music]
good honest hard-headed character is a
function of the home if the proper seed
is sown there and properly nourished for
a few years it will not be easy for that
plant to be uprooted
before we determine character from
Behavior we must consider the context
never does a man portray his character
more vividly than when proclaiming the
character of another
better to be a man of character than a
man of means
in the end it is the person you become
not the things you achieve that is most
important
sometimes refinement of character
happens naturally as we grow older but
for many people that growth is fostered
by spiritual practices adopted and
followed in a disciplined way
[Music]
any fool can criticize condemn and
complain and most fools do
but it takes character and self-control
to be understanding and forgiving
in order to persevere a person often
needs other character attributes such as
open-mindedness
it has a lot to do with character
intelligence plus character that is the
goal of true education
our attitude can be seen in our
character how we approach things what
our beliefs are our perspective on
issues how we approach life our position
on topics basically our view on life
another excellent character trait is
persistence no matter who you are or
where you serve or work persistence will
pay off in many ways
[Music]
it can be said that any one person's
overall character and demeanor is but a
reflection of the sum total of his or
her thoughts
develop your character so that you
become a person of integrity
you are your most important critic and
your conscience your most important
judge of character
our character is a composite of people
we have watched experiences we have had
but completely relies on the decisions
that we make
foreign if there is character
ugliness becomes Beauty if there is none
Beauty becomes ugliness
character is easier kept than recovered
the character of a Man Lies not in his
body but in his soul
when two men quarrel the one who yields
first displays the nobler character
one can easily judge the character of a
person by the way they treat people who
can do nothing for them
[Music]
the wolf changes only his coat not his
character
here that a mountain has moved believe
it but if you hear that a man has
changed his character believe it not
wherever man goes to dwell his character
goes with him
if there is righteousness in the heart
there will be Beauty and character if
there is Beauty and character there will
be Harmony in the home
if there is Harmony in the home there
will be order in the nation
when the character of a man is not clear
to you look at his friends
you don't get in life what you want you
get in life what you are
oh
character is that which reveals moral
purpose exposes the class of things a
man chooses or avoids
character is Victory organized
let us not say every man is the
architect of his fortune but let us say
every man is the architect of his own
character
[Music]
Character Matters leadership descends
from character
property may be destroyed and money may
lose its purchasing power but character
Health knowledge and good judgment will
always be in demand
in each human heart are a tiger a pig an
ass and a nightingale
diversity of character is due to their
unequal activity
[Music]
nearly all men can stand adversity but
if you want to test a man's character
give him power
[Music]
character is the basis of Happiness and
happiness the sanction of character
our character is basically a composite
of our habits because they are
consistent often unconscious patterns
they constantly Daily Express our
character
luck relies on chance labor on character
foreign
those who cross the sea change only the
climate they live in not their character
of all the properties that belong to
Honorable Men
not one is so highly prized as that of
character
by constant self-discipline and
self-control you can develop greatness
of character
Fame is a vapor popularity an accident
riches take Wings only one thing endures
character
when we see men of a contrary character
we should turn inwards and examine
ourselves
no man can climb out beyond the
limitations of his own character
success can never be measured by Bank
balances money measures only Prosperity
success is a matter of character
to succeed is nothing it is an accident
but to feel no doubts about oneself is
something very different it is character
every human being is intended to have a
character of his own to be what no
others are and to do what no others can
do
good character is not formed in a week
or a month it is created little by
little day by day protracted and patient
effort is needed to develop good
character
there is a great deal of self-will in
the world but very little genuine
independence of character
no change of circumstances can repair a
defect of character
our character is refined and tried by
fire when we have passed through the
furnace we emerge as pure gold and
silver
foreign
the best index of a person's character
is how he treats people who can't do him
any good and how he treats people who
can't fight back
power really is a test of character
in the hands of a person of Integrity it
is of tremendous benefit in the hands of
a tyrant it causes destruction
having a happiness that is built into
your character helps you to gain
confidence
if we are truly honest with ourselves we
can see that we each have many
characteristic flaws
especially when we are tired or hungry
these are the times that our character
is tested
[Music]
character is not cut in Marble it is not
something solid and unalterable
it is something living and changing and
may become diseased as our bodies do
if you want to know what a man is like
take a good look at how he treats his
inferiors not his equals
the development and contributing factors
of good character is the continual
process of understanding the components
and actions of love
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments